ja ich darf heute möchte was erzählen
zuständige zentrierter hochschullehrer
aus lärm psychologischer sicht das ist
ein sehr breiter begriff und er sagt ich
kann hier ganz einfach durch das
aufbocken das ist aber für die meisten
von euch relativ langweilig dass ich
mich auf die kern sachen beschränken
möchte nämlich was kann man machen damit
der lernerfolg der studierenden
möglichst groß ist und ein bisschen die
avocados die jahre spielen warum klappt
es manchmal nicht
also wir machen so schöne studieren
zentrierung aber irgendwie am ende kommt
nichts bei rum manchmal so manche
situation in manchen sitzungen und warum
ist das der fall
vorab es gibt den dass der kurzen spruch
konkret gemeint von allen versuchen
halte ich genauso viel wie ein beispiel
zu geben vermag ist ein satz den ich
sehr schätze auf mich bezogen würde das
heißen von einem studierenden
zentrierten dozenten halt ich genauso
viel wie ein beispiel zu geben vermag in
die klasse keynote besteht aus 60
minuten dauer vortrag mit passiven
rezipienten auf einer konferenz für
studierenden zentrierung fand ich etwas
schwierig dementsprechend kommt auf euch
teilweise eine kleine aktivierung zu als
keine vorwarnung
vorab eine kleine selbst erfahrene
anekdote als ich 2008 als doktorand in
berlin angefangen habe ich hatte sondern
erst mein zweites reguläres seminar
durfte ich einen kurs parallel zu meiner
erfahrenen kollegin geben dir foliensatz
stand wir haben also den gleichen kurs
bei zwei verschiedenen studiengruppen
die allem der amt studierten angeboten
und sich hat das relativ dozenten oder
lehrern orientiert gemacht also viel
power point viel präsentiert auch das
sehr gut vorbereitet strukturiert aber
hat klassisch dozenten orientiert und
ich dachte mir das mache ich anders ich
mache es studierenden zentriert und ich
hab dann also viel rumkommt zitiert und
versucht aktivierende methoden
reinzubringen hat doch alles geklappt
ich habe das ganze semester studieren
relativ häufig über aktivieren die
methoden angebunden und am ende bekam
ich meine der evaluation die war ganz
nett und dann habe ich natürlich
verglichen mit der meiner kollegin die
wir auch ganz nett
sie hat aber gar keinen großen aufwand
gehabt bei der vorbereitung der
veranstaltung weil sie hat jetzt schon
alle materialien gehabt nicht fakt ist
ja toll jetzt habe ich so viel energie
reingesteckt ist und auch alle
studierenden zentriert warum klappt das
alles nicht und damals konnten die frage
nicht beantworten haben nach so ein paar
eigene forschungsstudien in dem bereich
weiß ich heute warum es nicht geklappt
hat
und das soll heute den vortrag ein
bisschen dran kommen aber jetzt auch mal
zuerst die frage an euch und dass die
erste kleine teilnehmen und ihre aufgabe
überlegt man hat bei euch studieren und
ntt wäre nicht so gut funktioniert das
muss jetzt kein ganzer gesamt kurs sein
das kann eine sensation seiner methode
liegt nur kurz für euch seit wann war
das der fall und notiert oder
stichpunktartig damit wir später dann
noch kurz drauf eingehen kann egal
aber ich möchte drei probleme in meinem
vortrag hauptsächlich adressieren oder
angehen das ist der erste punkt den ich
schmerzlich erleben musste studieren
zentriert der lehre ist nicht
grundsätzlich immer besser als die
klassische lehrenden orientierte lehre
es die kunst erfolgreiche erfolgreich im
sinne von schlieren eben viel mit sie
lernen für was auch bedeutet aktivierte
studieren also die diskutieren die in
irgendeiner form aktiv sind
gruppenarbeiten projekt arbeiten lernen
nicht zwangsläufig mehr häufig aber
nicht immer und und das greift auch da
den punkt auf die lernziele was wir
erreichen wollen ist über alle lehrenden
aller universitäten und hochschulen
hinweg oftmals noch etwas diffus und
konzentrierte lehre ist nicht immer im
lernst mit drin und das ist ein
schwachpunkt und ich würde gerne auf
dieses vortrags diese drei sachen
verknüpft und gucken was kann man tun
dass das wirklich ein groß ist und
funktioniert daher auch familien ziele
die ich natürlich hier präsentieren
möchte
zum einen das wichtigste überhaupt das
lernt sie sollten die leute lernt ihr
vorher kennen
ich möchte ein bisschen was erzählen zu
idee und im hintergrund der studierenden
zentrierung also warum machen wir den
ganzen kram eigentlich dann wirklich
kurz aber umfassend so notwendige
aspekte guter oder erfolgreicher
studierte lehrer aufzeigen also worauf
sollte man achten sie auf die haupt 56
punkte
dann mich nach dem thema der kreativen
aktivierung widmen sich nach noch genau
was das ist tatsächlich kennt und noch
mal mit euch reflektieren was ist
eigentlich der angestrebten erfolg das
was wollen wir eigentlich am ende
erreichen bei den studierenden weil ein
erfolg ist nicht nur fachwissen oder
muss nicht sein
zunächst zu idee zum hintergrund von der
studierendenvertretung wenn man eine
sehr gute konferenz auf der homepage
anguckt und doch zitiert steht was zu
studierenden zentrierung geschrieben und
zusammengefasst kann man sagen was heißt
dass nach der definition dort und auch
der beschreibung dort wir fokussieren
uns auf den lernerfolg der studierenden
also wir wollen nicht sagen okay ich
mache es ja einen vortrag der
strategisch gut aber ob das jetzt zur
zielgruppe passen ist mir völlig egal
sondern es kommt drauf an dass die
studierenden und diesem falls ihr als
teilnehmer möglichst viel mitnehmen
ja und wir nutzen studieren zentrierte
lehrmethoden die meisten ihrer form der
aktivierung aufweisen also sprich in
porto lange rede ohne pause ist nicht
dabei aber viele andere möglichkeiten
von homophonen sachen aber auch von sehr
vielen klassischen lehre montierten
sachen wie gruppen puzzle diskussion
projekt arbeitet
und wenn man dann guckt wie alt ist die
inszenierung gibt es das schon lange von
den ersten studien her also aus den 15
jahren gab es eine spannende studie
herausgefunden hat das die die anteil an
themen fernen gedanken bei studierenden
in der klassischen vorlesung höher ist
ungefähr doppelt so hoch wie in einem
seminar wo man studiert oder wohin scoot
irrt die die studie von den 50er jahren
also die möglichkeiten von medieneinsatz
it-gestützte art waren noch eher gering
ausgeprägt als in heutigen zeiten auch
höher sein computer war damals schwer
mit reinzubringen die vorlesen weiß noch
ungefähr so groß war wie eine ganze
halle trotzdem auch da haben ein problem
ansieht das schon auch in der diskussion
die eigentlich anregen sein sollte wo
alle mitmachen haben wir bis zu 15
prozent die nicht dabei sind so das mag
menschlich sein aber ist ein problem
weil ich sie gerne alle hätten im
idealfall und es gibt zugleich erste
artikel zu studieren zentrierung in der
lehre auch aus den 50er jahren und wir
sind heute immer noch dabei nach wie vor
70 jahren das zeigt den großen paddock
bereitschaft der deutschen
hochschullandschaft
aber zumindest die ersten ansätze sind
schon relativ alt und so anfang der
nullerjahre gab es so den konkurs okay
wir haben eigentlich ein kontinuum von
der dozenten oder lehrern orientierten
einstellung informationsvermittlung und
auf der anderen seite die studierenden
zentrierung welche besagt dass man hier
ganz links klassische wissensvermittlung
8 also der stand ist passiv sitzt daher
zu und nicht der weise vortragen der
alles weiß fülle das leere glas mit
erkenntnis und dies wird dann wenn man
hier weitergeht in verschiedenen stufen
oder aspekten immer etwas studieren
konzentrierter bis hin dass wir hier den
ständen als einen unabhängigen lehrenden
haben und man ist als dozent er als
coach als lernbegleiter aktiv und hilft
dem studieren dabei seine wissen
struktur zu entwickeln basiert auf
verschiedenen ansätzen konstruktivismus
wäre er hier veranschlagt hier die
klassischen lehrern ansetzen
ursprünglich war das so ein konstrukt
mit zwei polen also sprich entweder oder
heute wissen wir ja sind zwei
verschiedene ansätze also man kann auch
sehr dozenten und hielt sein und sehr
studierenden zentriert hört sich an wie
ein widerspruch aber heißt man macht
eins von beiden je nach situation
man kann nämlich auch schlechte dozenten
montierung haben und spricht schlecht
vorbereitet keine struktur und das geht
in der hochschullehre auch sehr gut oder
gibt es zumindest er eigentlich sagen
wir hier das wäre unser optimum so 4 und
5 oder nur 5 die sind sehr studierenden
zentriert das frustrierende ist wenn man
den guten alten hätte auspackt der große
metaanalysen macht über sämtliche
reformen und studie und sonstwas hinweg
was einmal voll kreisten ist für lernen
auch im hochschulbereich dann kommt er
raus ja das erfolgreichste ist
eigentlich so hier zwischen zwei und
drei so die mischung aus instruktionen
wird so ein bisschen interaktion und
denkt man sich da bei diesen widerspruch
zu anderen schon die sagen naja aber
interaktive leute und viele aktiv sein
bringt auch viel
ja problem 2 oder was das ergänzt ist
hätte ich vergleicht alle
veranstaltungen ohne berücksichtigung
der lernziele hinweg über alles spricht
die einigen wollen mich so und die
unterschiede sind zwischen verschiedenen
formen nicht groß
wenn jemand sagt zu euch ja aber hätte
ja doch aus gefunden das bringt gar
nicht so viel kontakt
nur wenn man alles mit allem vergleicht
ja und dann kann man ja sowieso wir
sagen würde okay ich möchte von münchen
nach berlin war es das beste
verkehrsmittel und ich möchte von
münchen nach wladiwostok was das beste
verkehrsmittel
ja und die antwort lautet flugzeug bahn
ja weil man einmal besser ist flugzeug
nimmt weil die bahn nach platthaus doch
relativ lange braucht nach berlin kann
man aber ökologisch gesehen ob die bahn
durchaus nicht mehr so und das ist
problem gefunden sie vergleich von allen
lehrveranstaltungen hinweg das heißt
unter bestimmten voraussetzungen denn
die unsere lernziele passen ist
studieren sanierung sehr gut wenn ich
aber alles mit allem vergleich ist es
ein weiteres kleines problem wo der
wissenschaftler mir ein bisschen auf
schreit man darf nicht vergessen das
ganze hat eine leicht normativen touch
bei dem ganzen noch wir haben hier einen
studenten also passiert informations
empfänger und hier ein spenden als
unabhängig lernen denn die meisten leute
wird heute sagen okay ich tendiere er
dazu ja was ist aber nicht per sie
heißen muss das kommt drauf an fast für
einen sinnvoll erscheint fürs eigene
land ziehen
zur ehrenrettung der aktiven studieren
wir wissen aus studien von einer
vollmacht und selge oder so er nicht
skandinavien ich weiß leider die
richtige aussprache nicht das aktive
studierende eher tiefen lernstrategien
anwenden tiefen lernstrategien heißt
also ich habe das so durchdrungen
verstanden oberflächen laden ich habe es
mal so gehört das dann fix und tank zu
einem abkommen team entwickelt haben von
1 bis 7 also sieben verschiedenen leveln
die man erreichen kann also sprich auf
level 1 habe ich das mal irgendwie
gehörten kam ich gerade noch dran
erinnern fast immer weiter getroffen ich
kann es beachten also ich habe es nur im
kontext dass ich dann auch weiter roten
ampel stehen bleibe weiß rote ampel ist
ganz gut ich kann es nicht beschreiben
kann es erklären ich kann es in
beziehung setzen integrieren an wänden
und am ende gold sogar theoretisieren
wir wissen studieren zentrierung schafft
ist wenn sie gut gemacht ist schweren er
hier einzubringen lehrern ins
zentrierung wenn sie stand 30 gemacht
ist er nur hier ja auch da kann man
natürlich ein bisschen an allen
bereichen crm und drehen dass man auch
in andere bereiche reinkommt aber grob
gesagt studieren zentrierung ist
hilfreich um ein höheres level zu
erreichen
mit allen großen nachteil es dauert ja
man muss mehr zeit investieren tiefen
lang dauert immer länger
das heißt auch hier kurz ehrenrettung
des oberflächen lernen ist auch manchmal
sinnvoll beispiel grundschule das
alphabet man hat es gelernt und dann
wenn man weiß aber nicht wo der
buchstabe h herkommt wie den
geschichtlich und auch dass aus dem
genetischen alphabets sonst irgendwer
kommt ist wissen wir nicht ja und wenn
man den sprachwissenschaften studiert
wird man auch nie als tiefen lernen
alphabet machen aber das ist ein
hilfreicher oberflächen ernste machen
aber insgesamt bei unseren wichtigen
sachen lernt ziehen bei den hauptpunkten
die wir erreichen wollen im studium
würden wir gerne dahinkommen
so nochmal kurz zur einordnung von dem
ganzen wenn wir jetzt vereinfacht ohne
anspruch auf vollständigkeit sich uns
die klassische präsenz lehre anschauen
haben wir grob gesagt zwei
personengruppen die zusammenkommen an
haben die studierenden ihren kompetenzen
ihren werten vorerfahrungen die zu uns
kommen wir können uns das nicht
aussuchen
wir haben eine gruppe die irgendeiner
form bei uns auftaucht wir sind da auch
als lehrperson und wir haben diese
eigenschaften kompetenzen werte zum
beispiel fachliche expertise die
deutsche expertise vorwissen engagement
sonst irgendwas
wir bieten dann eine lehrveranstaltung
an die wir maßgeblich mitgestalten aber
nicht nur in der wir lernen sie
präsentieren eine gute struktur haben
eine angenehme arbeitsatmosphäre machen
die leute motivieren was auch immer die
lehre es möglich qualitativ hoch in der
hoffnung dass das was wieder angeboten
haben beim studierenden irgendetwas
auslöst an prozessen ein lernprozess
dann aktivierenden aspekten das
interesse steigert auch deren engagement
im ausland der veranstaltung zum lernen
forciert und auch ein aktive teilnahme
im sinne einer aktiven aktivierung
stattfindet na ich passe auf ich höre zu
ich versuche mir wissen anzueignen und
dies präsentiert am ende in irgendeiner
form von wirkung und ergebnissen das
dann zb studieren mehr wissen oder
vielleicht sogar fachkompetenzen haben
das wissen auch anwenden
es können auch methodenkompetenzen sein
dass wir für ihre studie durch wie
organisiere ich mich selbst wie gehe ich
ein projekt an
jetzt kann sowas sein die an transfer in
die gesellschaft was für relativ selten
noch adressieren
also ich gehe etwas zurück in die
gesellschaft engagiere mich sozial es
kann so sein wie dauerhafte begeisterung
für das fach oder für einen themen
gegenstand oder sowas wie
wertevermittlung ja bei manchen
bayreuther promovenden zum beispiel ist
das nicht ganz so gut gewesen im
politikbereich soll das ganze wird
beeinflusst durch rahmenbedingungen die
wir alle haben raumgröße temperatur
uhrzeit morgens um acht versus morgens
um 10 also das bildungssystem
lange rede kurzer sinn was können wir
als lehrer denn eigentlich auch da
vereinfacht gesagt wirklich nur
beeinflussen was können wir wirklich
stark forcieren und das ist letztendlich
natürlich das was wir können wir können
uns qualifizieren didaktisch wir können
uns fachlich gut vorbereiten können
engagiert sein und wir können die lehre
gut beeinflussen auch nicht immer
perfekt man kann schweren gruppen haben
die sich der schwer tun mit neuen
lehrern gegenstand wir haben in ihren
gruppen die sind läuft super gut aber
können die lehre in den meisten fällen
zumindest relativ gut beeinflusst
was er aber nicht beeinflussen können in
den meisten fällen sind die
rahmenbedingungen können da wenig machen
die kinder raum zugeteilt wir haben
einen unser testsystem die s4 sachen
festlich an der prüfungs ordnung und wir
können auch die aufständischen prozesse
nur bedingt beeinflussen
ich kann nicht sagen lerne ja aber ich
kann sagen aber man sagt mir stimmt
oder halt doch es ist nicht halt weil
ich es möchte und da setzt die studieren
zentrierung an aber verliert auch
einiges denn studieren zentrierte lehre
ist hier anzusiedeln
ich mache aktivierende methoden ich
engagiere mich die leute lasst die leute
wirklich arbeiten aber ich brauche hier
eine kognitive aktivierung bei den
studierenden das lernen was und das ist
nicht immer da also dieser teil hier der
ist nur bedingt
es ist nicht gesetzt dass ich eine
aktivierende methode macher dass leute
alle wirklich mit lernen das passiert
nicht immer plus das problem wir hier
was will ich eigentlich erreichen nicht
jeder aktive methode bringt auch immer
klassiker wäre ich meinen seminaren
sozialen kompetenzen und möchte das über
ein teenager ist am ende raus hin und
stellte fest ich kann nur wissen über
soziale kompetenzen erfassen aber nicht
wirklich wertevermittlung und performanz
und eine art spricht sind meine lernst
du dir wirklich aufpassen dass sie
abgestimmt
ja so viel zur idee und zum hintergrund
und ich möchte alle drei sachen also die
studenten zentrierung aber die
aktivierung und nochmal auf die
lernziele zurückkommen thematisieren ja
aber jetzt lange rede kurzer sinn wenn
ich jetzt quick and dirty beantworten
müsste was soll ich denn machen was ist
wirklich gute oder erfolgreiche
studieren zentren wie wenn methoden
anders kennt ihr alle deaktivieren was
also wie das nicht nur vorteile erhalten
von uns oder von turnieren
was mach ich jetzt kurz noch mal hätte
ausgekramt weil da sehr viel eigentlich
auch an zunächst positiven ergebnissen
drin stehen also die großen metaanalysen
anguckt oder dort klassische studieren
zentrierte ansätze anschaut also was wir
fragen stellen also nicht habt ihr
verstanden jahren ein sondern wirklich
tiefere fragen mehr komplexe fragen an
die studierenden dann hat das einen fast
mittleren effekt für die statistiker
unter euch dass ich lange genug warten
wenn ich fragen stelle klassiker ist wie
lange warten dozenten wenn sie eine
frage beantworten eine sekunde
ja und ich freue mich keiner von euch
gemeldet war ich hab doch lange gewartet
warum weil mein zeitempfinden viel
schneller ist war ich aufgeregt bin weil
ich hier rede
und da ist auch ein kriterium ich warte
lang war es sich für wissen aber vor
allem auch für kompetenzen sehr positiv
auswirkt und auch wenn ich ständig
fragen diskussion ermuntere also
kritisch zu sein nachzufragen das ist
sehr hilfreich
bezogen auf leistungstest oder hierauf
lehrer songs ergebnis es gibt auch am
rande nur kurz erwähnt eine spannende
fach unterschiede zwischen den einzelnen
disziplinen geist und
sozialwissenschaften sind meist
weiterspielen zentrierter als medizin
naturwissenschaften et cetera teilweise
bedingt sich das weil über physikalische
gesetze muss nicht zu diskutieren
also haben wir die gravitation ja ich
weiss nicht so recht und so weiter aber
definieren sie das mal das ist relativ
einfach aber definieren sie mal liebe
ja das ist schwieriger da muss ich
diskutieren ich muss studieren zentriert
sein ich muss aktivieren weil sonst ist
mein eine frage relativ schwer zu
beantworten und was reinkommt viele
studien untersuchen studieren
zentrierung aber über einstellungen
hier möchte ich ein bisschen vor warnen
denn einstellungen und verhalten
korrelieren relativ wenig also
eigentlich so stark zusammen das ist ein
problem aber oder auch ganz schön je
nachdem wie man sieht also sprich wenn
ich studieren zentriert und ich stelle
fest meine seminargruppe montags morgens
um acht zeit wohl mehr zugewiesen ist
verschlafen ja und sie kommt nicht in
die pötte und ist schüchtern und stur
sich dann kann ich studieren zentriert
sein aber ich wenn dies beibehalten und
nicht noch auch dozent montierte
ansetzungen einfahren damit die müssen
aktiviert werden damit es auf wachen ich
ein bisschen noch selbst mehr rede
und dann ist man seminarkonzept halter
da nicht so gut gelaufen und deswegen
also wenn ihr vom studieren zentrierung
reden lassen sie uns auch bei uns auch
verhalten gehen ja lange rede kurzer
sinn warum ist studieren sanierung nicht
generell nicht immer erfolgreicher
erstens es ist in vorbereitung und
durchführung weitaus aufwendiger als die
klassische lehrern zentrierung ja weil
erstens haben wir mal ist selbst mir
erfahren haben wir meist auch selbst
mehr gelernt war das muss man auch
vormachen wenn ich installieren sind
wird das seminar gut machen will muss
erstmal lehrern und sortiert gut
vorbereitet sein klassisches beispiel
wenn ich einen aktivieren die methode
mache zum beispiel nämlich ein artikel
aus suche bin ich diskutieren möchte
muss ihn vor gut gelesen haben ich muss
ich im thematik an gelesen haben wissen
was auch nebenbei noch existiert neben
artikeln das heißt ich könnte eigentlich
ein super lehrern und das seminar
anbieten mit ganz viel folien und sowas
und dann ist keine studierten zentriert
werden es dauert also länger und das
zusätzlich dürfe dabei ist es weist mehr
variable schwer kontrollierbare faktoren
aus ja aber ich habe leute die auch dann
irgendwie agieren aber die machen nicht
immer das was ich will nicht so schnell
wie ich möchte oder oder viel schneller
als ich eigentlich will
das heißt man muss einen wissen
mieter wissen haben einen blick für die
gruppe haben alle verstanden aber nicht
gerade noch daran oder auf facebook oder
recherchieren die gerade beim computer
das heißt es kann aus dem ruder laufen
das kann irgendwie nicht so gut laufen
ich muss also den gruppen fokus haben
und schauen ob die im buch steht jemand
und ja dadurch hat es meist höhere
erfolgspotenziale wenn es gut läuft hat
man sich war die stunde hat sehr viel
gebracht bei den szenarien zum beispiel
einer das sind super stunden aber es
kann auch eher nach hinten losgehen als
wenn ich vorne stehe meine 25 holen habe
hier unter erzähle und die leute hören
jeder weiß zu was auch ein grund weshalb
meinen würde beides vergleich traum blog
über alles hinweg ist nicht so große
unterschiede zwischen lehrern city
konzentrieren gibt ja weil man sehr gut
und sehr schlecht der 77 so übte kritik
was ist oder was es ist wichtig wenn man
schon die zentrierung nacht mehrere
punkte punkt eins ist für mich der
wichtigste und das war ein klassischer
fehler bei für die installierung sein
kann oder häufig passiert sagt häufig
aber die studien aktiv sind kann ich
mich zurücklehnen und hinsetzen und das
ist der kardinalfehler
ich würde argumentieren wenn die
studieren aktiv sind müssen sie hat muss
man als dozent gerade besonders aktiv
seien
natürlich aktiv das ich eingreifen aber
ein aktiven blick für die gruppe haben
also rum gehen und schauen wo steht
jeder arbeiten alle mit
brauchen sie hilfe dann muss ich
eingreifen oder soll ich mich das eher
zurückhaltend weil sie ja verstanden
haben worum es geht und ich würde durch
eine intervention den lernprozess
unterbrechen
das heißt wenn nicht so schütz ein
seminar habe ich arbeiten mit kleinen
gruppen und lasst alle zu dritt zum
beispiel eine gruppe bearbeiten würde
ist halt für mich heißt ok ich muss rom
gehen ich muss doch wo stehen die gerade
ja ok ja wir haben verstanden okay dann
kann nicht weitergehen und weiter oder
hakt und so weil ich fange auch mainz
den hinteren reihen an weil das häufig
die gruppen sind die für aktivierung
nicht so empfänglich sind zumindest für
meine gewünschte aktivierung und das ist
eine der gruppen fokus ist sehr sehr
sehr sehr wichtig was auch ein punkt ist
und das hängt jetzt aber ein bisschen
auch von der lernkultur ab ist es
trotzdem über das man versucht dass die
rinnen das gefühl haben sie könnten
prinzipiell immer dran kommen also jetzt
nicht zu jedem zeitpunkt des seminars
aber ein klassiker ist häufig und das
war mein fehler in meiner studierenden
aktivierung ich habe sehr viele
spannende aktionen gehabt in meinem
seminar 2008 habe immer den gleichen
leuten
und die band hat noch gute lernerfolge
die war super zufrieden aber der respekt
was man im nachhinein gemerkt hat und so
erhaltet ihr in der evolution und man
kann ein bisschen gegensteuern ebenso
gruppen puzzle macht oder methoden wurde
alle dran kommen müssen
falls interesse besteht kann ich die
beschreibung gerne zu mir hin oder auch
dass man sagt okay werden sie drei
gruppen schwer später aus wer von euch
dreien präsentiert das erzeugt eine
aktivierung ziehe der vortrag gestern
von ulrike hanke auch aufmerksamkeit und
sie wissen auch verdammt ich kann
prinzipiell drankommen das ist aber
natürlich nicht so schön studieren die
sagen auch ich hätte gerne mal einen
entspannten vorteil prozenten ich habe
ein bisschen zu so schöner lehrerin
desinteressiert vortrag aber ist ja
hilfreich
und das ist jetzt in ganz mannschaften
unseres herzens schafften weniger das
problem aber ist das normal
es findet ein kooperatives lernen statt
klassiker in jura viele bücher
bibliothek haben verschiedene seiten
nicht mehr
die wurden von den kommilitonen
rausgerissen ja bei dass die chancen auf
die eigene bessere note erhöht weiß
nicht ein nicht kooperatives lernen ist
das ist kein spaß ist ein großes problem
aber im fach jura weil die besten klinik
gute noten und wenn die anderen
schlechter sind habe ich meine chancen
gut umso besser so das bringt aber als
ich jetzt nicht wirklich viel für uns
war natürlich dann wenn jeder sich
gegenseitig behagt also immer kreativ
angehen lassen geht den gruppen arbeiten
meist auch ganz gut aber man trifft nur
gesagt
und wenn man gelegentlich so ein paar
sehr strebsam personen hat die viel
früher fertig sind oder die die gruppe
dominieren die redner dass man die
einfach mit ein paar
ich sehe nicht sonderaufgaben also das
nicht als bestrafung sein so eine
belohnung also spannende sonderaufgaben
neutralisiert auch das sind böse gemeint
sondern neutralisiert im sinne von dass
unsere kita alle sehr guten leuten eine
gruppe dass die anderen kommen müssen
oder das okay wenn es schon fertig sind
ich hab das richtig schweres für sie
machen damit er nicht die person den
rest dominieren und dass das die
studierens regierung gut funktioniert so
das wäre meine top punkte noch kurz zur
ehrenrettung der lehrenden zentrierung
oder auch der oder jeder form der
lehrveranstaltung es gibt ein paar
weitere punkte die ich empfehle zu
beachten wenn es gilt die auch in
lehrens und ihre wichtigsten die
konzentrierung das heißt kriterien zum
vortrag diskussionen zum thema der
gruppenarbeit interessante inhalte
lernziele zu beginn präsentieren ist a
und o gute struktur klare betonung von
gemeinsamkeiten unterschiede also
verschiedene konzepte theorie asb usw
da fällt das lernen statt genauso es ist
hilfreich wenn man gut in der rhetorik
ist es macht nicht viel außer was bringt
ein bisschen was klarheit und
verständlichkeit der rede ist relevant
und ein gutes leer
veranstaltungsmanagement also
störungsfrei also es nicht sei es im
vortrag diskussion dass man diskussion
moderiert also nicht ausrufen lassen
redet man fünf minuten ich gehe mal raus
pinkel und kommen dann wieder sondern
dass man schaut dass der rote faden der
diskussion halt erhalten werden
ansonsten anekdoten den maßen kann auch
mal hilfreich sein wechsel von input und
aktivierender methode sofern es dem
jahrzehnt methodenwechsel medienwechsel
redner wechsel sofern es dem lernziel
die abfrage und einbezug ständischen vor
wissens auch in a und o punkt und
emotionaler griffin hat kann immer
hilfreich sein
das war spannend oder ja wie mit dem
beispiel dem arzt welcher damals vor
dass pro wie als junger assistenzarzt
ich hätte fast irgendwie jemand über die
wupper gehen lassen sich jetzt warum es
nicht passiert ist warum was ihr machen
könnte dass euch nicht passiert alle uns
anekdote unterzahl ergriffen hat voll da
und alle passen auf so lange rede kurzer
sinn eine kurze aktivierungs methode
wenn noch mal überlegt was bei euch
nicht gut funktioniert hatte überlegt ob
einzelne der vorgestellten aspekte
schwieriges regiert er freue ich damals
geholfen hätte und wie es konkret besser
machen
dann mache ich weiter und möchte jetzt
die studieren sind rewe ein bisschen
ergänzen mit dem aspekt der sogenannten
kognitiven aktivierung bei auch wenn man
diesen gruppen focus hat es nicht
zwangsläufig sein was alle kognitiv
aktiviert sind warum
kommentiert aktivierung ist etwas was
nicht beobachtbar ist ja ich kann nicht
reingucken sagen oh ja die person denkt
gerade voll mit oder die person denkt
die partie heute abend konzipiert das
weiß ich nicht ich weiß nicht ob jemand
da ist aber ich kann versuchen über die
rahmenbedingungen meiner lehre stark
dass zu forcieren
und zwar das überschneidet sich ein
bisschen mit der studieren zentrierung
in den aspekten dort aber nicht
hundertprozentig ich kriege leute gut
aktiviert wenn ich mit ihnen
herausfordernde aufgaben
hohe aber erreichbare ziele das pusht
wenn ich konflikte provozieren
wenn ich die unterschiede herausarbeiten
lasse oder auch die odyssee zwischen
verschiedenen konzepten ideen positionen
wenn ich die leute dazu aktiviere selbst
aktiv zu werden ihre überlegungen
darzulegen
wenn ich herausfordern fragen stelle wo
die leute ran müssen
und gerade auch das mit bestehendem
wissen verknüpfen und wenn wir eine
diskursive unterrichtskultur oder
seminar kultur pflegen wo wir uns oder
die lehrerin vor allem intensiv über die
einzelnen konzepte austauschen
wichtig auch dass man einen kurzen
ergänzung warum lehrerin zentrierung
tages auch ganz gut funktioniert weil
das von den roten sachen abgesehen auch
umsetzbar ist
ich kann aber in einem klassischen
vortrag operativ herausfordernde
aufgaben stellen ich kein problem
konzept konflikte provozieren ich kann
auf unterschiede zwischen einzel
konzepten hinweisen ich kann auch
anregende fragen stellen es geht alles
trotzdem die zwei gehen nur bei studien
zentrierung das pusht das ganze noch ein
bisschen
das heißt also wenn ihr mal ja es geht
auch starken die motivation theorie rein
also wie bekomme ich leute jegliches
interesse da ist spannend damit kommt
man mit arbeiten oder das finde ich
interessant genau einmal kurz hält die
ausgepackt warum also das zu belegen
dazu gibt das was bringt auch da findet
man change aufmerksamkeiten engagement
ist sehr hilfreich für den lernerfolg
auch der fokus auf die lehre und die
lernaufgabe in der veranstaltung ist
auch sehr hilfreich und auch regelmäßige
statt gewalt übungszeiten sind auch
zentral
wieso sprechen von übungszeiten weil
lernen aktives lernen letztlich auch
eine übungszeit ist die man in seminaren
hat die man nicht noch nebenbei braucht
das prüft das ganze nichts mehr
genau
tja problem wie gesagt bei dem ganzen
sommer ich habe stets nur die person die
ich beobachten kann ich kann den kopf
rein gucken das heißt man ist immer nur
eine annäherung an das ganze und wenn
man sich überlegt welche diskussionen
man hat prozent diskutieren mit auch
sich forcieren sie dazu sagen aber es
sieht jetzt zu sagen und sofort habe ich
die aufmerksamkeit aber auch dann weiß
ich auch ob zumindest die beiden
personen mit dabei sind kognitiv 12 mal
sind es nicht danach sind sie meist
immer dabei weil sie wissen dass sie
dann kommen können auch die fall wie
kalt hochwertiges christus ist die
diskussion bei diskutieren können die
meist alle ganz gut
niveauvoll nicht unbedingt ne also habe
ich den text gelesen oder so
und ja wir sind die motive und auch die
selbstdarstellung in
diskussionsbeiträgen verteilt ist ein
hohes interesse da oder eher so eine art
ich rede gerne im internet
das als generelle problem
trotzdem kommen die aktivierung bringt
sehr viel auch hier nochmal kurz zwei
minuten aufgabe an euch
wenn es um focus habt was hätte euch
dann noch geholfen das würde jetzt mit
den jetzigen punkten anders machen bei
eurem konkreten fall
ich würde noch ein schritt aber gerne
weitergehen mit euch nämlich auf die
lernen strategien von turnieren und
davon menschen generell hingehen wenn
man guckt was für lernstrategien gibt es
also sich wissen selbst anzueignen gibt
es zu klassischerweise drei grobe
aspekte kognitive lernen strategien
meter community wlan schritte gehen und
die ressourcen bezogenen ressourcen
zogen können intern sein und in meiner
person gelegen externe ressourcen die
mittag und strategien sowie planung
überwachung regulation eigener
lernstrategien also sprich was habe ich
schon gelernt wo es nur an wo habe ich
schwächen und oben haben wir die
klassischen 3 die erste ist die typische
wiederholung strategie ist er nicht so
ganz optimal also sprich über den satz
immer immer wieder bissig das auswendig
kann und zwei besseren integration
strategien und die organisation
strategie kurz noch weiter klicken
können
was ist er operationen die integrierte
neues wissen in bestehendes wissen
hinein verknüpfung mit alltags
beispielen klassischerweise könnte das
der fall sein dass ich sage nehmt euch
eine anstellung raus wo es nicht gut
geklappt hat mit ständen sind dritter
lehre versuche das dann auf den heutigen
vor dazu übertragen das wäre eine
innovationsstrategie oder halt das
klassische mit aggression strategien
dass man sagt ich versuche mich selbst
zu strukturieren war mindmaps über
notizen sonst irgendwas er weiß dass es
macht die gleiche rechte jetzt kannst du
auch immer das nicht sagen
lerne als ich 25 zahlen miteinander
auswendig und ich mache eine geschichte
drumherum
und wenn man sich anguckt was können
studierende wirklich gut dann kann man
sagen davon eigentlich möglich nichts
das kann ich selbst mir auch attestieren
als student und wenn ich wüsste dass
oder damals schon das gewusst hätte wäre
meinen lernen weitaus weniger stress
nicht und meine noten in teilen auch
weitaus besser gewesen
leider sind die zeugnisse allen krieg
verschollen aber so aber warum ich davon
jetzt darum bereite es ist zwar sehr
weit gedacht sein pädagogisches noch mit
einzubeziehen aber wenn man die den
studierenden zeigt was für ein
schattiges eigentlich gibt und wie man
da vorgeht best practice mäßig hat man
zwar eine stunde verloren das ganze dann
oft er gezeigt hat es wirkt aber meist
ziemlich gut das kann auch ganz trivial
sein klassiker ich nehme hausarbeiten
aus vergangenen semestern sie sehr gut
waren und stelle sie anonymisiert als
best-practice-beispiele online ins
portal und machen eine korrektur
schilder mit meinen kommentaren dazu
daneben saß sie schauen können okay wie
korrigiere ich natürlich jetzt wenn ich
jetzt eine klausur schreiben dann ist
wie das andere
da muss ich dann auch da gucken aber
dass man einfach den leuten sagt okay
hier es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten
das kurz erläutert wie man richtig lernt
weil das dazu führt dass zumindest der
große schwierige dass er sich aneignet
und viel früher zu besseren ergebnissen
kommt ist sehr pädagogisch gedacht ist
aber glaube ich vom output er insgesamt
am ende
praktikabler beim beispiel den
haushalten erste mal habe ich mal
gemacht ergebnis war
der mittelbereich hausarbeiten als noten
23 und so wurde weniger die schlechten
blieben gleich viel spricht die haben es
nicht gelesen
so sei aber nur wenige aber mir geht es
so zum beispiel mit hausarbeit gerade
zwischen 2 und 3 dann brauche ich mal
sehr lange weitere korrektur rekordzeit
3927 usw
während 10 die kollegen recht herunter
und das geht ganz gut die fünf oder auch
aber
da bin ich ganz so befriedigt ja so viel
zur lernstrategien die erfahrungsgemäß
auch psychologie studieren oder
pädagogischen ihren meist nicht kennen
so genau
wieder nochmals zwei minuten für euch
was würdet ihr machen hat das was
gebracht findet das in eurem fall schon
integriert hätte die fenster nicht
integriert habe jetzt würde ich noch
einen letzten punkt nämlich gern eingehe
nämlich die frage des sogenannten
ständischen lernerfolge
das ist jetzt nichts wo ich sage hier
gibt es eine allgemeine empfehlung nach
dem motto machen sie immer das denn wer
sich anguckt was kann man alles
vermittelt hat man so die eiligen die
wollen mich so man kann nicht immer
alles machen man kann sich aber auch
sachen auswählen und das ist jetzt keine
sache man vorgaben von außen wirklich
hat außerdem ein bisschen bei die module
beschreibungen der prüfungs ordnung
sondern auch viel eigene kreativität
einsetzen kann
also sprich ich könnte sagen ich gehe
auch ein dekoratives wissen also ich
kann zu benennen
ich kann aber auch mit fachkompetenz
oder auch große doch alles wissen
anwenden ich könnte auf
methodenkompetenzen gehen wie schreibe
ich eine hausarbeit eine
qualifikationsweite die forsche ich
korrekt
ich kann über soziale kompetenzen gehen
das muss nicht heißen ich bin nett zu
wandern sondern sorgst du was wie die
arbeit ich erfolgreich in teams zusammen
kurzfristig beruflich zentral ist
zweithäufigste weiterbildungsmaßnahme
das ist ein betrag im bereich hin also
bei firmen oder ich kann auch personale
kompetenzen gehen das was wie die
begeisterung die motivation für ein fach
werte aber auch oder auch noch weiter
medienkompetenzen zu andere verschiedene
aspekte problem ist es dabei auch das
ist immer schwer zu messen beziehung zu
beobachten weil ich kann über die
performanz gehen von einer verraten
diskussion der krise ein gefühl dafür
ich kann objektiver etwas über noten
gehen die sind aber auch tafel subjektiv
vom dozenten der dozentin gewählt das
gleiche auch ich kann über rückmeldungen
auch gehen auch da kann ich besuchen die
relegations nutzen wollen
es ist alles nicht so hundertprozentig
perfekt gerade wenn ihr nicht über zu
prüfende fachkompetenzen sowie soziale
kompetenz mache das prüfen ist welt die
schwierig eigentlich müsste die leute
neigen situation schicken die sie nicht
vorbereitet sind und sagen so jetzt hab
ich ein schauspieler der moderiert
irgendwas unterspielt irgendwas sozial
inkompatiblen die heute müssen agieren
so aber man kann versuchen sie dann
lange rede kurzer sinn was wollt ihr was
wollt ihr in euren veranstaltungen
vermitteln das variiert klar je
veranstaltung und wären wir jetzt mal
wieder das alte modell ausgekramt was
ich empfehlen würde immer zu machen ist
überlegt erst hier was wollt ihr
erreichen also was ist das lernziel was
ist die intendierte wirkung des ganzen
wo wir am ende stehen
ich mache das auch immer zu beginn des
semesters eine art best-of szenario also
wenn alle alles wirklich gut hinbekommen
wo wäre ich dann und dann würde ich mir
was aus diesen bereichen passt dazu
was hilft mir wirklich also wie in
deinem beispiel nicht nur die methode
methode wählen sondern welche methode
passt perfekt für mich
das kann schon ihren zentriert sein muss
aber nicht also klassisches beispiel
wenn ich ein seminar in
wissenschaftlichen arbeiten erstsemester
mache und ich komme zum punkt
zitierregeln der deutschen gesellschaft
für psychologie
dann bin ich so was von dozenten und
lehrenden orientiert weil ich nicht so
diskutieren da muss ich mache den punkt
doch eher nach dem vornamen oder nach
dem ersten buchstaben des fordern das
ist einfach klassischerweise
wissensvermittlung so mit spätere
anwendung und prüfung dann aber erstmal
wissensvermittlung und weil man lernt
sie hat das dann nur wissen ist und das
wäre aber dass der punkt also guckt was
wollt ihr erreichen
genau das kurzzeit gründen nie machen ja
ich bin normal eurer veranstaltung
rekurriert hattet ihr ein konkretes
lernziel und wenn ja war das gut
abgestimmt zu den studenten zentrierten
methoden und zudem werden generell und
zu der aktivierung und wenn ja super
wenn nein was würden sie anders machen
fazit
die konzentrierung hat ein großes
potenzial sowie ein freund von dem
ganzen aber ist nicht immer generell
besser sondern stets ein mittel zum
zweck
das wäre mein zentrales für euch also
das wichtigste ist nicht dass die studie
konzentriert sein das wichtigste ist
dass hier lernziele habt die ihr
erreichen wollt die ihr gerne erreichen
wollt und dass sie das rauskommt was
euch am besten dazu ihn führt das ist
häufig für die konzentrierung also muss
aber nicht immer auf lernpsychologie
sicht also wenn die frage was möchte ich
erreichen welche ansätze hilft mir dazu
und da kann ich übrigens mit ihm machen
meist ja dann bitte wenn nein aber
gleich weg damit die lehre ist nicht
schlechter die lehre ist gut wenn sich
haben daran zu orientieren
herzlichen dank